le projet majeur et prévoit la
construction d'un gazoduc de 550 km de
l'ontario vers le saguenay pour
transporter le gaz de l'ouest canadien
il prévoit aussi la construction d'une
usine de liquéfaction d'un par
méthaniers pour acheminer le gaz naturel
vers l'étranger mais ce projet évalué à
9 milliards divise la population
tincani qu'ailleurs au québec il ya peu
plus d'acceptabilité sociale pour le gnl
québec que pour le pas et de loin nrj12
transcanada deux côtés des résidents des
environnementalistes qui se mobilisent
qui s'opposent au projet qui parle juste
d'économie youbi social environnemental
et dans les faits ses potes de la con
durable du projet là de l'autre le
gouvernement des élus régionaux des gens
d'affaires qui voit des retombées
économiques des emplois payants pour la
région avant même qu'ils aient des
évaluations environnementales de fait
nous disons un oui conditionnel en
octobre dernier une quarantaine
d'économistes québécois ont publié une
lettre ouverte critiquant le projet on
remette en question les retombées
économiques non je pense que pour le
bien de la planète ait ouvert à cette
possibilité là entre autres que du gaz
naturel liquéfié qui soit une énergie de
transition qui remplace en europe et en
asie des centrales au charbon des
centrales ou si nucléaire le bureau
d'audiences publiques en environnement
doit commencer évaluer le projet à la mi
mars
mais les débats s'annoncent chauds
d'autant plus que le projet pourrait
être affectée par la crise autochtone
ici jean philippe robien à radio canada
montréal